one of the problems with our food system
that hasn't gotten anywhere near enough
attention is that it's ultimately based
on the exploitation of poor workers
mainly recent immigrants in this country
that's true and you look at the the
restaurant industry and fast-food
workers it's true when you look at the
meatpacking industry and who's working
in their processing plants but it's
especially true in the production of
fresh fruits and vegetables just about
every you know healthy fresh fruit
vegetable produced in the United States
is still harvested by hand and the
people who are harvesting our healthiest
foods are being paid poverty wages and
exploited in the last decade there's
been so much interest in animal rights
and then the abuse of livestock in the
meatpacking industry and yet there's so
little interest and there's been so
little attention paid to the violation
of human rights in our food system you
know you can become a vegetarian or a
vegan if you oppose the mistreatment of
animals and the meatpacking industry but
if you want to eat a healthy you want to
have a healthy diet in the United States
and eat lots of fresh fruits and
vegetables like we're supposed to you're
connected directly to the exploitation
of workers to incredible human rights
violations that are routine in the
fields and not just in Florida where
much of food chains is set but also in
California just about anywhere where
migrant workers are in the United States
you find incredible abuses well if you
were to talk about the abuse of Margaret
workers 30 40 years ago a lot of the
blame would have rested with the farmers
who were just trying to squeeze extra
money out of their workers for their own
profit but today it really isn't the
farmers and growers who have power over
their workforce
it's the companies at the top of the
food chain and that would be the big
fast-food companies the big supermarket
chains which are the largest purchasers
of these agricultural products and they
squeeze their suppliers all the way down
the line
and at the very bottom literally at the
bottom of this pyramid are the workers
the workers in the field and they're the
ones whose wages are being cut and whose
working conditions are suffering in
order for the fast-food companies and
the big supermarket chains to make a
little bit of extra profit what workers
are increasingly doing is looking at the
real power in this industry the gigantic
multinational corporations the fast food
companies and supermarket chains and
insisting that they pay a little extra
for their produce and that they adopt
standards of conduct so that you know
the suppliers aren't involved in this
sort of abuse and the coalition of
Immokalee Workers a farm worker group
based in Florida has had tremendous
success in the last decade with this
very approach looking at the real power
in the industry and insisting that they
be held and accountable for the poverty
wages and for the terrible working
conditions in the fields when I say
terrible working conditions I don't just
mean that it's hard work it's really
hard work you know in the hot Sun it's
back-breaking work but beyond that and
it's sort of incredible in the 21st
century that there'd be slavery
literally slavery in the fields as
undocumented workers are basically
traded by their smugglers to labor
contractors and forced to work for free
and in the 21st century this may seem
like a radical view but we shouldn't
have slavery in the United States I
think most people don't realize how bad
these working conditions are in
agriculture and the fact that you know
there's still systems of indenture that
are more reminiscent of the mid 19th
century than they are with a 21st
century
you